every minds are definitely anyway I mean
all the different philosophies beliefs
ways of doing things the way we pick
teams
however we work at the court is a
player's overlooking before we enjoy and
where's the clip I couldn't buy a new
Barcelona he's got a pedicure is no
David I and I love his press conferences
I mean they are growing I mean I could
be somebody's press guys stretching and
the seats as if he has for some of the
questions and it's good that he's got
the confidence to do with her we have
this exaggeration of a world-class
player is but then you take why the
reason that sebum is in Ronaldo the
consistency first of all the balance
that excellence on the ball of courage
they're never ever painted by a tackle
the up give me the ball the goals of
score the level the pinna the Middle's
of 108 points at one thing those two
players and I think most players in the
world probably one would agree with me
these two guys that above the ground
they were using in the gymnasium a night
time a date with school kids and they
all heard the coaches so his whole day
was a bit training in the morning
practice after training practicing
afternoon couldn't the gym in a time you
know that goal is scored at Wimbledon
that's no I was not an accident
he practice kicking a ball for ages
that's why he can do that so the
practice ethic that these players had
Tim fair level that you know surprise
your findings or runners-up in the promo
week since I started then make sure we
want it so that tells you about recovery
not I wanted to kill you defeat and
doing something about it but nothing has
won proud of the interesting thing about
is ultimately I never would like
whatever it were achieved a one I never
I never done with me to would kill it
and analyzing and Joya you know that
there's always I'm moving on to the next
one to the next one and I think know
that you know as you said a nerve
retired and reflecting on those years it
was a fantastic career as unbelievable